i love this guy i don't care who knows
it i enjoy our conversations he always
shoots it straight uh whenever i chat
with him
um and he's back here on the rich eisen
show with his tampa bay buccaneers
getting set to take on the rams
on monday night football after
dismantling caroline a nice bounce-back
victory for the tampa bay buccaneers
head coach bruce erins
back here on the show how are you coach
yo great rich how you doing buddy
i am better for talking to you all right
you are now uh
10 weeks into the season have you
learned anything about tom brady that
you did not know about
in these 10 weeks
a lot a lot i think the biggest thing
and how great a job he does with young
players
you know he's like having another coach
out there you know i'll tell a kid to do
something and they pump your arms on
this and
i gotta tell them five times tom said
hey can you pump your arms on it oh yeah
sure
interesting so it's like the parent that
doesn't get hurt but
uh the peer gets heard pretty much in
terms of no doubt
no doubt and uh yeah when he speaks they
all listen and uh
all like little puppies uh so it's been
great um
unbelievable competitor and uh love
everything about him
what do you say to somebody like brady
uh after
uh the loss you had against the saints
because in terms of being unprecedented
i mean you
usually don't get beat like that either
yourself but
he's never been swept by a division
opponent before and he's 20 years in
what do you as a coach say to somebody
like brady after
something like that let's go look at the
tape and figure out why
you know um he's kind of like me
he's going to watch it that night and uh
with the early early next morning and
and get to it right away so uh get the
answers and um
hope and pray we get a chance to play
him again well that would be uh
a third time around obviously and then
your uh
your your team moved on very well
against carolina
um my colleague kurt warner looks at the
tape looks at the film of your offense
and says brady still doesn't look
comfortable completely comfortable would
you agree with an assessment like that
coach oh totally totally i mean each and
every week it's it's
a learning experience of what
byron and i know what he knows and
meshing them all together
against a new opponent every single week
we're finally starting to have the same
players out there with him
um as far as receivers we had a little
bit of different offensive line this
week for the first time but
so yeah that's uh it's been a learning
experience and it is every week you know
having no off season no preseason games
and all that
really set us back so what when when do
you think that
comfort level hits i mean we're you're
there there's only uh
so much runway left in this regular
season coach
uh probably next spring
when we're all really comfortable no
kidding so but you basically have to
deal with that for the rest of the
season
in that regard huh i think so yeah look
now
we should be better when we play a team
second time around which we weren't
uh we were good against the panthers we
were terrible against saints
um so yeah we played you know we haven't
played falcons yet so
uh so when you play them the second time
it should be a little bit easier this
time it was
it was way off it was horrible bruce
erin's here on the rich eisen show but
and then you've added
a new receiver um and not just anybody
it's
it's antonio brown um were you
look the off the field stuff is the off
the field stuff and i do want to ask you
about that in
in a minute but put a pin in that and
ask you just the idea that you're where
you're
you're trying to get comfortable in
offense you're adding somebody new
is there was there any hesitancy on that
front just to begin with
coach well yeah basically back in the
spring was no
uh in the fall it was no and then when
mike was down and chris was down
and and you're losing pro ball players
and there's a pro bowl player available
after week eight they pretty much owe it
to the rest of your players and you know
me i'm gonna ask all my veteran guys
do you want this guy on our team and
that to a man yes sir well we
we think he's gonna help us win for sure
um
and he's been you know he's been great
since he's been here and uh he knows
he knows the rules we put down and he's
he's
been fantastic so far well and again
you're you're
uh just in terms of of brown and what he
brings to the team uh
offensively that's one thing um i i do
want to ask you this bruce because i
know one of the things that you have
been
all about is women's issues and you have
you haven't just uh walked talked the
talk you've walked the walk you have you
have brought
women into football in a way that other
coaches don't
and some women's groups were were
wondering why you would bring antonio
brown in
have you had conversations with anybody
on that front and what would you say
to them about that yeah i've answered
i've answered that one a few times rich
and it's
you know trust me i mean
i think what you said the record of how
i've
pioneered for them just trust me in the
fact that
i'm gonna give this guy this chance and
it's just a chance
and let all that handle itself in the
courts
and um all i can ask them to do is trust
me on it
bruce arians here on the rich eisen show
so
uh about this team on uh monday night uh
this is one i didn't see coming
in terms of um story lines for the 2020
season that the bucks have trouble
playing at night
and it's something you as a coach need
to address i didn't see that one coming
is there an issue with your team playing
at night coach
it has been so far it really has been so
far so we can't dodge it we
we've we've gotten off to terrible
starts
in in all three uh night games so far
and uh
we're so we're going to change some
things up practice at night do some more
stuff monday morning
than we have been to hopefully
get off to a fast start you know it's
when you're playing monday night
football
you come to the stadium expecting all
this excitement
and you walk into the meadowlands and
there's no soul there
and it's almost a letdown so we've got
to figure out ways
same thing in chicago you're going to
soldier field and there's nothing
it's just you and the other team so you
got to build that up yourself
um we have a few fans here and
i thought that would help us it didn't
against new orleans we got to a very
slow start so
yeah we got to try something different
what are you going to try what are you
putting into place
that maybe you're friday and saturday
night we're practicing that game time
so that we get used to that and then
monday mornings
uh we'll get up do some um
light exercise stuff and then have some
meetings and hopefully
kill some of that day the sunday night
football you can watch you
watch games all day but right tonight
that's soap operas and taking naps and
getting ready right so i i mean have you
ever experienced this with a team
obviously you you mentioned empty
stadiums as an issue
um clearly that's never happened before
but have you ever in
any of your days college pro uh seen a
team that
might have an issue uh with a night game
have you seen that before
our first our first our first year
in arizona um when teams don't play it
in prime time
very often it sometimes they get over
hyped
which can also come that make you look
like you come out flat but you're over
hyped
uh and i think you have to learn how to
play in prime time
you know the steelers playing primetime
all the time so it was never anything
for us
and bill cower always practiced on
friday night whatever time the game was
scheduled for
we did not do that with mike tomlin but
uh so it's um
i think you have to learn to play in
prime time especially in
2020 when it's really dead in the
stadium
bruce arians here on the rich eyes and
show a couple minutes left with the
coach
of the tampa bay buccaneers uh we have
on monday a segment here on this show
uh coach called overreaction monday my
colleague gives me
a statement that people are maybe saying
in the media and i say it's a reaction
or or not uh overreaction or not uh
one that he threw me yesterday says
outside of brady the most important
player on offense for the buccaneers
could be ronald jones
would you agree with that assessment
coach
i i think the running game
you know the the running game as much as
ronald jones and leonard fournette
the running game would be the next most
valuable yes so
um because it provides the balance
that's necessary
um and and it's amazing
it's amazing how one week it's difficult
for you to run at all or
you're so imbalanced because of the
score and then the next week you get
95 more yards on one single run
potentially than you had all previous
game
yeah you know i mean that's yeah that's
the beauty of the game but uh
you know the new orleans one was more me
trying to get something jump started we
went to two minute offense real early
right to try to get
something going and it just it didn't
work
so that that run that four four or five
runs whatever it was that's all on me
and then before i let you go uh
something that i'm sure you're not
thinking too much about but uh we in the
uh media certainly i
uh noticed these things uh what's with
the box that you're wearing across your
chest
what's what's that about where did that
one come
the that's just the normal belt yeah
right
and i have to wear that so tight it
affects a nerve in my leg
and uh so i started wearing on my
shoulder and i haven't had the problem
with the nerve
on my leg during the games is that right
so
and uh yeah one of our doctors said you
know that belt so tight
that can cause that problem it's like
the superficial nerves like you got
shingles right
burning down your leg the whole time of
the game so i was like let me throw it
over my shoulders see if it works
instead
it's a hell of a lot more comfortable
voila just like that
and then you and then you've gone face
shield and then
the thing across your chest and then all
of a sudden you're just
you're more focused on the game
essentially is what you're saying
much easier much easier it's a lot
cooler without that match how about that
okay
well just wanted to these are the things
i noticed you know and i just want to
make sure that uh yeah a couple people
have asked me about it yeah because i
know that goes around the waist
usually and not you know over the
shoulder like that
but is for a good reason it's a fashion
statement okay that's two
it does look good on you i'll tell you
it does look good on you thanks for the
call coach really appreciate it
it's more slimy rich thanks brother
it's like stripes is that what you're
saying it's like vertical stripes yeah
vertically
whatever whatever yeah whatever it is
it's working looks good on you though
uh thanks for the call coach let's uh
chat down the line
um and uh best of luck to you moving
forward
appreciate it thanks any time brother
that's it that's uh tampa buccaneers
head coach bruce sirens